discuss can you call them a terror group
can we have a disc can you call them a
terror group are you prepared to call h
a terror group is it possible to have a
rational you is it possible come on
answer that question you can't can you
no it's my show you answer my question
15 times here is Morgan asked him to
just say that Hamas is a terrorist group
now keep in mind this is the same
question that was posed to AOC in the
halls of Congress we showed you that and
Rashid Tali and ilhan Omar and they
refuse to say it they don't think that a
group that breaks into someone's borders
and randomly with maximal violence and
and just like un
Unthinkable evil does all of the stuff